video-on-demand now open to pro members
they are offering 90% of the revenue to
producers
although the pro membership does cost
$190 a year do you view this as a viable
revenue stream for any producers moving
forward and overall what do you see as
the pros and cons of the new on-demand
well I don't think that a $200 a year--
is detrimental if it's that detrimental
to you you're really in the wrong area
filmmaking is going to be overwhelmingly
expensive for you there maybe you should
try painting writing poetry or
photography or something that's not as
expensive because $200 is not that much
for distribution yourself it does not
answer anything to the traffic driving
traffic to your page you know - to
getting the revenue it's the same
problem you would have on iTunes on
Netflix on Amazon VOD on Hulu any of
those other things that having access to
the platform is great having no audience
not knowing who is going to go there and
get them to come to your page and buy is
a universal problem you know and this is
this new tool is not going to solve that
you know they aren't necessarily
curating I mean they do have staff picks
and things like that which is helpful
but staff can't pick every film you know
so if you happen to get that great you
know recommendation that can lead to a
bump in sales but that still doesn't
absolve you from the responsibility of
having to to get drum up that audience
and drive them to your page now I would
suppose that the pro page has in sites
where you can see the analytics and
where the traffic is coming from I don't
know if in the payment scheme they give
email addresses because it's new so I
don't know what's happening with that
but that would be helpful you know for
you to be able to see okay if I run a
Facebook campaign and I drive the
traffic to Vimeo which is a known
platform and I can see the dashboard
behind it to see whether what I'm doing
is making an impact that's way different
than what you do when you send people to
iTunes or
Hulu because they keep the analytics you
don't have access to that so the
difference to me that the competition is
not really with Vimeo and iTunes or
Vimeo with Netflix its Vimeo with a vhx
a dystrophy a dynamo player any of those
other tools where you can have the film
on your website and stream from your
website and an app for a fee because um
Vimeo is known and your website may not
be known so people who are used to going
to Vimeo just like they're used to going
to iTunes you know to get entertainment
they're used to going to Vimeo to see
films and shorts and all that kind of
stuff so that gives you access to a
bigger pool of people who are used to
going to a site rather than the pool of
people who just go to your own site but
the good thing is it's non-exclusive so
you can have it in both places so if
you're driving traffic you can drive it
to both places you know obviously from
your own website there will be a
percentage that you have to pay to
whoever is hosting your film in the
first place as that tool unless you're
selling it via PayPal or something where
you've set up your own system and your
aren't going through another hosting
service but Vimeo I think is going to be
a good tool for that 90/10 I don't know
anybody who's giving a 90/10 split but
the challenge is still getting them
there making you know getting them to
pay that that doesn't change just
because because Vimeo is now offering
pay for per view rather than free
you